Speaker 1: Republicans in 2023. And
the American right wing movement is
fundamentally about we are the victims
and about grievances. Even though the
right loves to say all these leftists are
constantly making themselves the victims.
Be it of racial bias or gender bias or whatever
the case may be, it is actually we on the right
who are truly the victims. And one of the big
avenues during which they through which they've
claimed this victim victimhood is through
big tech. Twitter is prioritizing our content
ideas that are simply questioning the status
quo. And conventional wisdom of COVID vaccines
are being shut down and we are being silenced and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And even though they
love to say these left wingers got to stop with
the grievances and with the we are the victims,
it is really the right that has played that
card. And the most interesting aspect of it
is that every time it's been tested, every time
it's been investigated, every time it's been
looked into in some detail, it turns out that
that is actually not true. Republicans latest
ridiculous claim is against Google and it is a
claim of bias and it has been debunked. They tried
to say that Google spam filters in Gmail were
biased against conservatives. The idea was the
spam filter is not merely making a an impartial
analysis of what should be redirected to your
spam folder. It is using Partizanship, whereas
Repub wherein Republican fundraising emails are
much more likely to end up in spam than Democratic
fundraising emails. Emails from the RNC are much
more likely to end up in spam than emails from
the DNC, and it has now been studied by the FEC.
And the determination that's been made is that's
just not the case. And of course, the right is
outraged. The right says that the analysis itself
is biased. But the truth is that whenever these
things are looked into, we are unable to find
evidence of bias in the investigation. And the
investigation is unable to find evidence of bias
in the underlying phenomena which they are looking
at. The FEC looked into it and determined that it
was not true. Now, this is not actually surprising
and it's not surprising in two different ways.
It's not surprising when it comes to the RNC
and it's not surprising when it comes to Google.
And I'll deal with each of those aspects one by
one. The RNC and the Republican Party and right
wingers and MAGA, you know, whatever, all of them,
they have been grasping at straws trying to prove
big tech has a liberal bias. And the truth is that
that has not been determined to be the case. When
you looked at I mean, just go through it one by
one, when there was an analysis done of Twitter,
it turned out that that was not the case. If you
by the way, now that Elon Musk has taken over
Twitter, there's this new thing called the for
You feed. It's basically a sort of algorithmically
curated feed not based on it's not the people you
follow. It's sort of like a stuff you might be
interested in. It's just right wing trash. I went
on there and it was Kerry Lake anti-vax COVID
skeptical stuff. The left is censoring. What
about Woke Anti-woke anti-trans? It was crazy.
Okay, so Twitter wasn't found to be the case,
especially not now. Under Elon Musk's leadership.
It's become a right wing platform. Facebook? Well,
supposedly Facebook is very much biased against
the right they so they claimed then an analysis
was done every single week, including leading up
to the election. After the election, well before
the elections, 2020 2022, the best performing
content on Facebook is almost exclusively right
wing content. Dan Bongino, Ben SHAPIRO. All these
types of people. Every once in a while there's a
Rachel MADDOW clip that makes it in there.
The top stuff on Facebook is right wing stuff.
Now G.M.. Okay. So it's not surprising. And this
idea that there's just constant liberal bias in
all big tech has been disproven time and time
again. The RNC made the claims about Twitter
before Elon Musk spotted it. It was dismissed,
etc.. Now, there's another aspect to this.
Republicans are trying to make campaigning against
big tech a big part of their election strategy
because, again, they are the party of victimhood.
They are the grievance politics people.
And it may still work like it doesn't actually
matter if they can keep campaigning on big tech
is biased against us. It might still be useful to
them, but then we get to the Google part. Listen,
I am no generic defender of Google. I mean, just
in the same way that I'm no generic defender of
any platform, but having spam filters
that are biased against conservatives
would not be in Google's interests in any way.
Google is a business. Its primary goal is to
make money and alienating a large segment of the
population through such partizan spam filtering,
or even if it's not overt. But if campaigns don't
convert. And these right wingers start to realize
it's Gmail that's preventing the campaigns from
converting by sending our emails into spam.
It wouldn't be good for Google's business. It
wouldn't be good for Gmail's business. So there's
really no reason that they would do it. And so it
doesn't make sense on any level. And it's time,
I hope, for the RNC to move on from these
conspiracy theories and from the grievances and
from the victimization focus on real issues. There
are things you could do as the Republican Party to
maybe actually convince some people to vote for
you based on based on good ideas, rather than
just more grievances and more complaining and more
whining. But once again, it's been studied, it's
been debunked. And of course, they will say the
study itself was biased. Hey, you have to see this